welcome to bananamores this next comic
is responsible for most of my wrinkles
caused by all the laugh lines
you think i was on the floor
oh thank you thank you so much
you you you've held me down you've held
me down for so long y'all might not know
this
but when i was down and out you know i
was on i was on a big plush banana couch
able to get back on my feet back when i
was hitting set and only
only only mitzi had me thank you
i know i know i'm supposed to be real
goofy right now but i had to i had to
get that off my heart
real quick i had to get that off my
heart uh but yeah we have a nice
intimate set here we you know we got all
the anime figures sitting around you
goku's funko pops you know they
they watching i'm having a good time i'm
ready to get back out here
this has been it's been a long
quarantine it's been a it's been a long
quarantine i don't know how all of
y'all's quarantine been but mine
i've been buying stuff i've been buying
so much stuff which is why i'm staring
at so many anime figures right now
but i i've even been letting the social
media algorithm just pitch things at me
and
seeing you know what i want to buy and
it made sense at first
at first it was making sense you know it
was like black hair care products you
know fitness things things that apply to
me the algorithm was working
but i think i was buying too much
because at some point
the algorithm got confused and it just
started just throwing whatever it could
they're like he'll buy it so let's just
get the weird stuff
let's just get the weird stuff and like
one time
it even like pitched at me a backyard
beekeeping kit
the time i didn't even have a backyard
so that was weird
uh even even more so i don't know a
single
black person that messes with bees i
don't know a single one
if you know a black person that messes
with bees
that's that's the candy man so you
should start running you should get away
i can only do that joke four more times
then he comes to kill me those are the
rules
hope you hope you up
another quarantine core purchase
gorgeous
as as as i may say sometimes i've got a
got an electric vehicle i was like i'm
gonna leave it i'm gonna leave gas
in 2020. i'm gonna get an electric
vehicle but i got one of them
self-driving joints
uh and and i'm hyped i was i was real
hyped to get a self-driving car
but the thing they don't tell you about
getting a self-driving car is the things
that you're excited about
uh no one else is gonna be excited about
like like i'll be talking about with my
friends like yo
this self-driving is tight man i was
able to fall asleep for five
minutes while driving and nothing
happened and they're like bro
you shouldn't be doing that what you
talking about what you talking about
like that's why we get he's like no no i
don't want you out on the road anymore
i don't want you out in the room but i
think i'm thinking look this is how we
go in the future
let's let's stop driving ourselves let
the car do the drive you know there's
too much human error
i may be the only one who believes this
but i'm gonna let's ride into the future
if you got a self-driving car i don't
want you all use me as excuse for
falling asleep behind the wheel
all right all right all right look
i got to get out of here mitzi said
don't take too much time up here
so you know i got a split even though
it's been appealing set
but i gotta haul potassium yeah you knew
you were gonna get some banana fans i
can't be behind a giant banana
and not do a few banana puns but i'm
getting up out of here
i'll see you later look guys somebody
get another drink to goku right here
somebody get goku another drink because
that that's been empty
for my whole set so let's get you out of
here but i'm going to give it back to
mitzi
thanks for for watching me taking time
out of yell day
and i'll see you all next time was that
good for you it was good for me and it
was good for the banana